Life on Earth emerged at least three and a
half billion years ago as prokaryotes.
These are the simple unicellular organisms.
They have a membrane on the outside and a
wash of cellular machinery inside, all mixed
together and touching, and sharing the same
environment.
This worked, certainly.
Life chugged along this way for nearly half
of the history of life on earth.
But then, 1.8 billion years ago, something
remarkable happened.
Something that led to a tremendous shift in
the scope and complexity of life.
Something we should all be grateful for because,
without that leap, we would not exist.
Cells started to...contain cells.
Now this isn’t generally how it’s talked
about in science class.
There you hear that Eukaryotes have quote
“membrane-bound organelles.”
These are areas of the cell that are separated
from the rest of the cytoplasm by membranes,
just as the cell itself is separated from
the rest of the universe by its membrane.
It turns out, different activities require
different conditions, and these cells within
cells allow for those different conditions.
That, in short, is the secret of Eukaryotic
success.
But how did it happen?
Well, over decades of study we have determined
something shockingly peculiar.
Something so odd that it makes us kind of
mad that we now discuss it as if it isn’t
the miracle it is.
1.8 billion years ago, a cell consumed another
cell...but then it didn’t digest it...it
let it reproduce inside of it, and they lived
together, and, over time, became the same
organism.
Or did they?
This is what we call “Endosymbiotic Theory.”
Mitochondrion appeared when the consumed cell
was adapted to live in an oxygen rich environment
and chloroplasts appeared when the swallowed
cell was photosynthetic.
This idea was deeply controversial when it
was first proposed, but as data have continued
to come in, endosymbiotic theory has been
able to explain more and more about the realities
we find.
For example, that chloroplasts have their
own DNA which they use to create the proteins
required for their function.
And as we dive deeper into the microcosmos,
it just becomes obvious that this happens.
This is Paramecium bursaria, a single-celled
protozoa, that has several hundred algal cells
from the genus Chlorella living in its own cytoplasm, making it green.
The algae live inside Paramecium bursaria
providing it with fuel in the form of sugar
and other substances produced via photosynthesis.
And Paramecium bursaria provides protection
for the algae from algae eaters and viruses.
P. bursaria is regarded as a predatory protozoa,
it feeds on bacteria, small organisms, and, yes, algae
and because of that it's often
thought that the algae in it are temporary symbionts
engulfed by Paramecium bursaria’s feeding
behavior.
But in fact, many other protozoa acquire algae
in that manner for temporary use, but that
is not the case for P. bursaria; its symbionts
are continuously inherited from generation
to generation through cell division.
The symbiotic Chlorella guide the Paramecium
to well lit areas, so they can photosynthesize
more efficiently.
The mutual relationship is extremely beneficial
for the Paramecium.
Even when the Chlorella-containing Paramecium cells are put in nutrition-free saline solution they
can survive for more than 3 months while cells that didn't have Chlorella died within a week!
This is another single-celled organism with
endosymbiotic algae, it's a testate amoeba.
A kind of amoeba that builds itself a shell.
This species, like some kind of sculptural
artist, pulls bits and pieces of mineral from
its environment to create these amazing looking
homes.
You can see the amoeba extending from the
opening of the shell and you can see the green
algae in its cytoplasm.
Just like Paramecium bursaria, the algae
use sunlight to produce food sharing it with the
amoeba while the amoeba provides protection.
Some unicellular organisms don't need oxygen
for growth, indeed the presence of free oxygen
can affect them negatively or even kill them.
These organisms are known as anaerobes.
Such as this one, Metopus.
It is an anaerobic ciliate we find in pond
sediment and it has an endosymbiotic relationship
with methanogenic archaea.
Now we haven’t talked much on this channel about archeans, but they are the third domain of life, along
with bacteria and eukaryotes and, like bacteria, they are prokaryotic.
We can’t wait to do our episode on them someday soon.
Many of the single-celled eukaryotes living
in anaerobic environments contain symbiotic
prokaryotes, some of these prokaryotes are
methanogens, meaning they can use free Hydrogen
to generate energy and methane.
The advantages of having these symbionts are not fully understood
but while Metopus can live without the symbionts
they grow faster when they have them.
Endosymbiosis occurs in multicellular organisms
as well.
This is a freshwater relative of jellyfish
and sea anemones, Hydra!
It's simply stuffed full of algal endosymbionts.
We collected this Hydra from a nearby pond
and cultured it in our aquarium.
The benefits provided by the symbiotic relationship here have been well documented, with scientists
actually tracking how carbon moves from the
environment, into the algea, and then into
the hydra, and studies have shown that up
to 69% of the caloric requirements of the
hydra is satisfied by its algal symbionts.
Nice.
So, we see, some organisms temporarily pull
in symbionts, others pass them from generation
to generation.
Some can survive without them, and some cannot.
When we look at the algal cells in P Bursaria,
we’re forced to ask if those cells
are part of the organism, or if they’re
simply cells of one species living in the
cells of another.
If that’s the case, it’s worth asking
whether the mitochondria in you are you at
all, or if they are just another extremely successful species of prokaryote that is particularly reliant on
its host cell.
As we look deeper and deeper down, the line
between organisms is harder and harder to find.
Which is why, if you think hard enough you might begin to feel like our cells are more
than just ourselves.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds...and
inhabits us.
Journey to the Microcosmos is produced by Complexly,
which produces over a dozen shows on YouTube,
including Scishow
And we wanted to let you know that the SciShow team has just put out
a really interesting new episode
This year, of course, marks the 50th anniversary
of the first time humans walked on the moon.
And to celebrate, SciShow made their first documentary.
The team traveled throughout the US.
I even went to the UK to talk to experts.
trying to figure out
whether the moon landing was actually a good idea.
and they got some really interesting answers, but I won't spoil them.
You can watch the episode at YouTube.com/SciShow or by clicking that link in the description.
If you want to see more from our master of microscopes, James
check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more form us,
That, my friends, is what that subscribe button is for.